i've found it the most frustrating thing
in the world that having got into
parliament i'm talking about
disadvantaged kids i'm talking about
disadvantaged communities
working-class communities how do we
improve on this nobody paid the blindest
bit of attention
until i started saying white
working-class boys
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissing
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations
with fascinating people we're delighted
to say that joining us today
is the member of parliament for
mansfield ben bradley mp welcome to
trigonometry
hi how you doing it's good to have you
on the show man
we're excited as we were just talking
before we started
we don't ever have serving politicians
on the show we we've made one or two
exceptions in the past
for people that we thought actually
would speak their mind
and and be direct and honest about stuff
so hopefully we can get you cancelled in
the process of this interview
plenty of people have tried i'm just
pleased to be described as fascinating
i'm happy with that i can go now
yeah well listen for anyone who doesn't
know you and doesn't know who you are
and what your background is you became
the first conservative mp for mansfield
since
1885 right you are
quite a lot younger than both francis
and i so you're quite remarkable in a
few different ways
you've done all sorts of jobs in your
past just tell everybody a little bit
about
who are you how are you where you are
what is the journey that brings you
uh to where you are uh now which is
sitting here talking to us
yeah sure it was almost an accident to
be honest um we
as you say you know manchester's never
had a conservative mp um
it was liberal and and before labour in
the early 1920s so it's a bit of a shift
politically it was a proper kind of
hardcore labour coal field
uh territory um and and personally you
know i always want to be a pe teacher
actually i went to uni to be a pe
teacher and
in the end kind of changed my mind and
dropped out and worked as a landscape
gardener i worked at aldi and frankie
and benny's and
various other places and decided in the
end to go back and do something that
wouldn't
railroad me down a particular route um
something kind of broad at
uni and pick politics which um very
effectively railroaded me down a
particular route and then actually fell
out with my council about the bins it
got me really grumpy
you do look like the kind of guy who's
there on the tuesday morning
take my booze absolutely that's that was
me at the age of like
21 um and uh ended up doing this
petition round and getting all the
little old ladies on my estate riled up
about the bins and and decided to stand
for council and never look back really
just um
kind of fell in love with it i mean what
what a story ben
it's all started with the bins i mean
that's what people get passionate about
when people talk about local council and
local politics
it's inevitably the bins but you're in
the conservative party
now the conservative party had this
massive win
at the general election um and you saw
seats like yours turn away from labour
why do you think that is it's been going
on for a long time
and the shift if you look at since 1997
mansfield was an eighteen thousand
labour majority then it came down to
eleven
eight six five and and went conservative
in 2017
um and then this time you know i had a
thousand majority then it's 16 and a
half now so it's a big old shift
um and it's been happening as i say
since since then so
um if you look at not just corbyn not
just brexit those things kind of
accelerated it but actually it's the the
cultural shift
you know for all the history of labor
voting very unionized industries really
everybody voted labour
um they've always been kind of small c
conservative when it comes to culture
and values
um you know and having broken that that
labour connection
you know seen jeremy corbyn and what he
was about and didn't fancy it um there's
maybe more of a willingness to look
elsewhere
and kind of figure out what those values
are and really you know
the stuff that we talked about in 2019
in particular you know tough on law and
order
um a bit more kind of patriotic
a bit more um you know leveling up and
supporting those those poor communities
was right up that street
do you think that you uh you and others
in in the red wall seats in the red wall
areas do you think that you have
shattered that tribal allegiance that
people
in those areas used to have for labor
where you know
my dad voted labor my granddad voted
labour that sort of thing do you think
that's
a permanent rupture or do you think
you've got this
tiny window and as boris johnson said
you have to now
prove to people that the vote that they
lent you
was worth lending uh to you i think the
latter um
certainly broken the allegiance right
because i mean you heard i heard in 2017
even more so in 19
you know my granddad would turn in his
grave if if he knew i was going to vote
sorry
um but they did and kind of you know
sucked it up and closed their eyes and
mark the cross kind of thing um and we
do have to show it
there's no sense to me at the minute
that kierstama or labour have
won anybody back over from that
perspective but obviously
you know kobe is really challenging for
many reasons people are
pretty depressed largely um so so no
huge swell of support for the government
either and
we do need to show over the next three
years that we're going to do something
worthwhile with this parliament and
make it worth it particularly that
investment in those communities and and
wanting to see something that that
tangibly makes things better where they
live
um so there's a big challenge and you
know if we prove the point then they'll
stick with us
uh if not it will be a matter of time
before
you know labour figure out what they're
doing and offer them an alternative
don't you think we're in this quite
weird time ben where
conservatives represent the working
class better than labor and then let
labor have become the party of the
middle class liberal elite
it's a big shift isn't it and breaks all
the stereotypes i think um
you know they've always been that kind
of um academic
uh islington socialists in the labour
party it's always been a bit of a
an uncomfortable mishmash certainly for
the last 20 odd years between them and
and you know the working-class um kind
of core vote but actually we saw all the
way through
uh through brexit and more recently some
of the cultural discussion about that
that disconnect between the two and
they just they cannot rub together uh in
those big
um kind of statement conversations
things like brexit where actually it's
it's those islington academics who
um not only don't agree with the kind of
working-class uh lead voters but
actually
can't stand them um and that's a real
problem uh when it comes to trying to
tie together that political coalition
right so
every party has those divides there's a
kind of liberal or and more kind of
right-wing divide in the conservative
party as well
um but at the minute we're certainly
speaking more for those communities i
think
and and brexit is indicative of that in
it
well we weren't going to spend too much
on brexit but you bring it up and one of
the interesting things is
all three of us in this conversation
voted remain because we're good people
that's the running gag on the show we're
very moral people
but equally all three of us i think have
a tremendous amount of respect for
democracy and for the people who voted
differently to us
what was that like for you representing
a constituency
that voted differently to you in the
referendum
to be honest it's been fine i i voted
remain on the basis but
i think like a lot of my generation i'd
never given the eu a second thought to
be honest
um i wasn't born when we went in it's
just what i've always
had and hadn't particularly to be honest
as i said before
i fell out about the bins and went back
to uni and what have you i'd never
really thought about politics i wasn't
interested
um so it was an odd one i kind of just
went along with what was easiest
if i'm being totally honest i've got no
um
no no quarrel with i didn't have a
quarrel with european union i think
it seemed like there were problems i
don't want to be part of a federal
europe but
actually was it in the too difficult box
was it really worth it and it wasn't
something that was important to me so i
just kind of stuck with it but i
understood the arguments
i always have and and um since we
actually voted to leave i think they
come out even more clearly so
it's not been that difficult to fall out
with the eu since then has it and some
of the things that they've done and the
way that they've approached this
this negotiation so as we've gone on you
know i've kind of just embraced it and i
think um most constituents who pay
attention to what i do and say
have recognized that so we've not really
had a problem at all
i mean i was firmly in the camp that
i thought to remain within the eu was a
good thing
we voted to leave the vote should be
respected i thought it was the wrong
decision
at the time and for many years after
that one thing that really changed my
mind
was the behavior of the eu over the past
couple of weeks with regards to the
vaccines
what is your what is your opinion on it
yeah sure i i think
that things like that just prove the
point don't they um and we saw it
throughout the negotiations where
um you know there was a point at the end
of last year where they were going
absolutely mad about us saying well if
this doesn't work we might have to break
international law in order to
um to make the northern ireland
situation work and they went crazy
um but they are quite happy to break
international law when it comes to you
know the germans
um bidding for vaccines behind the eu's
back when they've signed up to treat it
it's when it suits them isn't it and
um i think that's one of the things that
uh really wound
a lot of lead voters up previously is
i'd never really thought about it but
actually we've seen since 2016 2017
a lot of examples like that and um i i
think we're in the best possible
position now to be able to do something
positive
a colleague actually described it to me
in a really helpful way um
that i use all the time now and it just
said look if you're you're sat in the
back of a car as a passenger
and you're headed in a direction that
you know you don't want to go which is
federal europe you know handing over
those powers to a big
um federal system then there's only so
long you can tell them to slow down or
tell them to turn around
before you've got to get out of the car
um and go your own way you know so
from that perspective brexit was always
inevitable it was just a case of when
which
i think is quite a neat way of
explaining it actually yeah it is
irrespective of
the the underlying issue with the eu and
so on
i think it would be difficult to argue
that brexit has not been a hugely
divisive issue that has
really polarized the country that split
really yeah
you know typical i'm trying to do the
british understatement i'm
not not very good at it but it's really
really
hurt a lot of relationships your
families
you know we have this fever pitch
conversation in our media now
that you know there's a lot of animosity
that has been generated
how do you think we we start to bring
people back together because that's a
real worry to me that
everything now is a 11 out of 10 in
terms of anger and outrage and all of
that and
you know brexit was clearly a big part
of that yeah it's really challenging
isn't it and it seems the first example
of that kind of divided
um discussion but there are lots now it
seems like everything almost falls into
that category i think kovid does to some
extent
you know and i think the media and
social media has a lot to answer for
because it always
uh ignores the grade isn't it it makes
better headlines to have
the extreme versions and pretend that
there's nothing in the middle when
actually most people are in the middle
um i think brexit's like that uh you
know i i
think most people remain or leave were
able to see the other argument and able
to
although they disagree actually kind of
understand what the conversation was
about but it's not those people that end
up
as the talking heads on the political
shows is it and and making the headlines
and you know kovid's kind of the same
you know
whether you're locked down skeptic or
whether you're um you know
wanting to keep us locked down forever
that's always the way it's portrayed
isn't it you either want to kill
everybody's granny or you want to lock
everybody in their homes for
for the next whatever and there's
nothing in between when actually we're
all in between
so i do think there's a huge um media
problem
there but i do think people are getting
more and more wise to it um
the challenge i suppose is that when it
is such a polarizing angry debate those
people who are in the middle the people
who
who have the relatively mainstream kind
of view just stay out of it
you don't want to get involved you don't
want to um cause an argument because
it's not worth it we're very british and
from that perspective we'll just you
know you
have an argument and i'll back off um
which which leaves just the very loud
angry voices out there doesn't it
amplified by things like twitter and all
of that so
leaves me and francis out there which is
great for us but ben
i mean it's a very good point you know
we do see tend to see the angriest
people
amplified on social media etc etc and it
seems like
the most important issues aren't the
ones that get discussed about because
it just turns into a shouting match into
a slanging match
one of the things that i'm very worried
about and part of the reason that i'm
glad we have a conservative government
is the economy and what state the
economy is going to be
after we've moved past this because you
know
for for us it's been a good thing in
because we've been able to grow
we've got a captive audience all the
rest of it but for the vast majority of
people
this has been a complete and unmitigated
disaster
i'm glad you're doing well um
silver lining um yeah no it's massive
isn't it and
unfortunately with with you know
vaccinations being where they are
and with um the level of kind of
business support you would hope
we would be in a better position than
most to be able to pick up again when
things open up
and we've done more than most countries
to protect business and employment and
and all of that so all being well um
you know we're in a position to be able
to pick that back up but we're going to
have to deal with huge unemployment
uh we're going to have to deal with um
lots of
not even just people being at work but
those businesses and those jobs not
existing and we're going to have to
create them somewhere else
um so there's lots of strands to that
right the the skills stuff that was not
a couple weeks ago i think is really
important further education and
shifting people across into the sectors
that are growing because like you guys
said you know you guys have done well
other sectors have done well
um you know particularly the kind of
logistics and all that kind of stuff
you know big amazon warehouse opened
near us which has
helped us to kind of soften the blow a
little bit because there was an extra
thousand dollar jobs there just as they
were disappearing
in other places so it's a long term game
though um
that's the challenge and and you know
what the worst thing would be to think
you know we got making 10 years ahead
here where do we want to get to
to get to three years time and end up
letting bloody
labor take over and and do it all up
up the wrong way so it has to be a
long-term plan and i hope
you know we can convince people to stick
with that plan but equally
the debt the spending is so big that you
can't expect to just
whack up a bit of tax here or to cut a
few things there and fix it it's a long
term
approach to dealing with all that as
well well i was going to make that point
you mentioned that britain has done more
than other countries to protect
people and businesses from the economic
impact of what's happening
and i think you know a fair observer
would say that's accurate
equal question that a fair observer
might ask is
can we actually afford the things that
we've done and the things we're yet to
do because
that as you say the debt and the deficit
which runs up the debt
are so massive now we have spent so much
money
and we have paid you know a good chunk
of the country not to work for the best
part of a year
the time we're recording this can we
afford and how long can we afford to
keep this up because it's
incredibly expensive isn't it yeah we
can't afford it and
if we were just doing on what we could
afford we would have stopped a long time
ago um
but i don't know what else you do um
that's the thing and i think for a lot
of conservatives in particular who are
you know like me traditionally you know
small state personal responsibility
you know all of this stuff is so far out
of my comfort zone
that it's not even worth you know
discussing it's just
in normal times i would never ever
support measures like the kinds of
things that we're doing at the minute um
but as i say it's it's either that or
let things go to the wall isn't it so
we kind of are where we are we're gonna
have to deal with it and i think the
battle now
for people like me is to say right how
do we get back to
um a sensible position in terms of um
people's independence and personal
responsibility and what the state should
be doing and then kind of
remove all of that um kind of creep that
there's been over the last year
um without kind of damaging people
because that's you know almost a slow
and steady process as well i guess if
you can't just
take away a load of things all in one go
um and to try and convince the treasury
um again that you know actually it was
talking politically earlier on if we're
going to win the next election if we're
going to convince these these former
labour voters stick with us
we've still got to invest we've still
got to build that infrastructure we've
still got to make those places
better than they were at the start of
all this so you can't afford to just
pull the plug on that either
and it's going to have to be one of
those as i say very long term games in
terms of managing that debt because
there's nothing you can do to flick a
switch and just pay it all off it's not
going to happen
and i mean what one of the challenges
that the conservative
government is going to face and it's a
very very tough one is
you know cities like london it will
bounce back it always does
it's you know it's an economic hub but
places like mansfield or places in the
northeast
who have who have suffered this hit it
is going to take far more for them to
regenerate
yeah sure and there's a report out uh
last week i think about coal fields in
particular that said they reckon they've
knocked a decade of progress off of
coal field communities in terms of
things like employment
um and people's kind of increasing wages
and standard living so
huge challenge there's opportunities as
well though right because
um for all the the negative stuff
there's been some change
in that people are working from home
lots of businesses have discovered they
can work from home lots of businesses
will have discovered they don't actually
need to be based in london
they don't actually need to be based in
the city um
they might not need is bigger premises
and there'll be lots of changes in how
how
businesses work so actually if that's
the case you don't need to be in
nottingham anymore why not get a cheaper
premises in a place like mansfield why
not employ people
outside of the city if we can get those
transport links and and that kind of
investment
um you know it makes potentially some of
those towns on the outskirts of some of
these cities a more attractive place to
to start a business and to employ people
um and then we've got opportunities on a
national level like
um in the east midlands we've got
proposals around like free ports some of
the stuff we can do
post brexit that is is uh has a huge
amount of potential so
there's stuff there we just got to tie
it together and and
you know put that infrastructure in
place that means you can go and start a
business in a
a mansfield or a barnsley or a stockport
right rather than having to go into the
big cities and
and do everything from there um it
doesn't happen overnight
but we're talking a good game at least
at the minute we're just going to get
outside
owned wrecked
destroyed hey constantin do you like
social media
yeah of course where else am i going to
destroy people with facts and logic
but what if i told you there was this
great new social media platform that
allows
you to create live podcasts which lets
our fans connect with us in real time i
know all about it it's called stereo and
it lets our fans connect with us via
voice messages directly in live podcasts
it allows you to get up close and
personal with your favorite performer
you know what i'm talking about ladies
so you can ask
any question you like except is constant
in here legally
correct i'm a resident of panama for tax
purposes but the great thing about
stereo is it allows you to connect with
your favorite musicians comedians and
youtubers
it is so simple that even francis can
use it
all you have to do is download it from
wherever you get your apps and it is
dead easy to use click on the link below
it'll take you straight there we've
already done
two live shows that are exclusive to
stere and are not available on any other
platform
we talked about classic trigonometry
stuff the eu big tech center ship
and other types of top level banter
here's an exclusive 30 second clip for
you to enjoy
think of how many people now want to
[ __ ] with the system
yeah that's quite impressive
how many people now don't feel like the
system is working for them
don't feel like uh democracy reflects
the will of the people all of that
don't feel and people are starting
frankly to become aware
of how badly they've been screwed over
and i think people are tired of this
idea that
we we have this managerial financial
we're doing a live show on stero again
this coming friday the 12th of february
at 1pm
join us there for this exclusive show
and become part of the conversation
well you mentioned talking a good game i
want to move on to
some of the cultural stuff that we talk
about on the show quite a bit
and i think you've really made a bit of
a name for yourself by being
uh quite automatic problematic is what
your critics might say
or brave is what your supporters might
say but you've spoken up about
you know men's issues you've talked
about all sorts of cultural
things and you know talking a good game
i think
a lot of people felt particularly at the
last election that the conservative
party
uh even which one that they didn't
necessarily feel
super enthusiastic about was their last
chance
to hold this cultural
shift that we are seeing what people
refer to as the culture war
and that while the conservative party
may not offer a perfect solution they
were the only opportunity to to hold
that
advance obviously covet comes
it gets in the way of a lot of that
stuff and i think there has been some
frustration
with with the conservative government
that they're not doing enough on the
sort of critical race theory
and all of that sort of stuff uh what
how do you feel about how your party is
doing on that front
i think you're right about people seeing
it as the last chance you've seen what's
happened already and just in the first
couple of weeks of abiding
administration in the states and
really going to town on all this stuff
and embedding that identity politics
i think that's it's it's awful um some
of that to be honest
i guess for in terms of performance um
there's an element of just
uh you know how many hours are there in
a day right with with brexit and
and uh covid but now we can hopefully
certainly move on from the brexit
stuff as things come together and you
know towards the end of this year
be free of covered stuff and actually
have that capacity but in the meantime
there's been
been things going on i mean you guys
will no doubt have seen um some of what
liz trusts and and kevin badenock have
been doing in the equality office
and kenny gave an amazing speech on um
yeah
that was very impressive um and liz
looking at changing
uh moving away from that equality act um
focus on identity politics on physical
characteristics and instead
what are the the real inequalities that
drive people's life chances social
economic status geographical
inequality and things that get ignored
by the act and i gave a
i held a debate in westminster last year
about how i think the equality act
actually disadvantages
certain um really disadvantaged groups
or discriminates against them
you know on the basis that if if i'm a
really rich well-connected
black lad from hampshire i can get more
support based on the acts than a
a poor working white class uh poor white
working class lad in mansfield
um despite the fact that i know that
that white working class lad has the
worst life chances of any group in the
country so
it doesn't make sense and finally we're
getting that i think and starting to
look at
what are the individual issues that hold
me back as a person as opposed to what
category am i in what box can i be put
in
and i think that's a really important
step actually it's early days
um but liz certainly seems committed to
making some some big changes there
is that something that's well understood
within your party because i can tell you
with with a tremendous amount of
certainty that there's a lot of people
particularly in areas like yours
who really passionately care about this
stuff and if
if the conservative government doesn't
deliver on it they're they're going to
be upset about it
and you know everybody including us is
going to hold your feet to the fire on
this one
yeah sure and and it's really important
i keep making the point to anybody
who'll listen
uh in number 10 about um you know we
talked about 2019 election
it wasn't one on the basis that the
conservatives normally win elections we
normally talk about it being kind of the
economy
uh as the key conservative thing but
actually
it wasn't this time arguably we were
telling the country that we were not
prioritizing the economy we were going
to do something that many people said
was going to be damaging we were going
to do brexit and that was
bad for the economy according to every
analysis
so what we were talking about was the
cultural stuff it was getting tough on
law and order
um it was you know offering that
the ladder the opportunity to people who
don't currently get it
that equality conversation but in a very
different way but if we don't deliver on
that equally you know if we're just
going to be
labor light then what's the point in
voting for us you know
we'll vote for labor so we have got a
huge challenge and we need to really
dig on this reform there's some big
stuff we can do whether it is the
equality act
whether it's the human rights act and
dealing with some of this illegal
immigration things like that that are
really um
winding people up in my constituency at
the minute but there's opportunities to
fix it
big flagship changes we can make um that
will make a real difference
being brave enough to do it isn't it as
you say and
tipping enough people over the line to
get it done and ben what would you say
to those critics particularly on the
right
of the conservative party both culture
and economically
who say that the conservative party is
many things but it is not
conservative sometimes it feels like
that
um but to be honest but i think
um you know the last year has been
really hard doesn't it and
you can look at it and go right i
believe in small government i believe in
um you know lower spending and more
independence i believe that
you know ultimately um your life and
your
life chances are your responsibility and
then government puts the framework in
place but you've got to go away and do
it and then the last year
um all that's on its hair doesn't it
because we've paid for everything
and funded everything and taking away
people's freedoms which is not
something that i would hope any
conservative politician ever came into
um to politics or into government to do
so it is a bit
mad at the minute and a lot of those
things like i said earlier i would never
ever consider supporting in a normal
time
so we've got to get back to some common
sense at the end of all this and we've
got to get back to
dealing with those issues in a different
way and that's an interesting argument
because there are lots of people who
have pushed for from you know bigger
state more control more regulation than
all the rest of it even in the
conservative party who are very happy
uh that we've got some of that so there
is a a battle and a conversation to be
had
uh even internally but um you know
ultimately uh
there are enough colleagues in a lot in
in senior positions who are pretty sound
and sensible
uh there and certainly you know the
stuff i've just been talking about the
equality stuff
um and lots of stuff around the human
rights act and whatever in the home
office stuff that's happening it's
already happening
um so we're on the way we just need to
get through covid and get back to
something like a normal state of what
government's meant to do
you know and we talk about and
constantine uses the phrase hold the
feet to the fire and
isn't that worrying that that's not the
labour party doing that that's people
within your own side and your own party
having to hold the conservative party to
account
because labor i mean let's look at their
last election result have become a total
irrelevance
yeah i mean the challenge for them right
so not only have they lost
loads of seats they've lost all the
seats in the kind of what i would call
the sensible
northern working class look at him he
looks gutted about this doesn't he just
it's so upset on behalf of that
absolutely devastated um you know
i wish that they were much more
vociferous and winning all over the
place but sadly
uh it's not gonna happen for a while i
hope but you know but because they
brought in the corbin intake right
although corbyn's not there
anymore so many of their backbenchers
are from that kind of corbyn easter hard
left
um agenda so and even the ones who
seemed sensible right lisa and andy was
coming around the country after the
election saying how do we figure this
out
and seemed like she knew what she was
doing and then she decided this week
they should scrap the army and have an
international peace force instead
um you know it's just just nutty so
they've got a real challenge to try and
overcome it but
you know maybe that's uh
for the betterment from a government
perspective in that israel's
um you know on the the more more
conservative end of the conservative
party staying right
come over and join us as opposed to
being dragged off in the other direction
um yeah i know what you mean
i voted for different parties throughout
history and from my perspective
i you know i voted conservative for the
first time in my life at the last
election
i want a strong labour party i want a
labour party
to be holding you guys to account uh you
know obviously there's certain things on
which i don't agree with the labour
party but
there's a lot of things that they're not
doing and it is frustrating
to see just how disorganized and and and
disheveled they look at the moment
because we do need
a strong robust debate on on many issues
don't we
sure absolutely it's healthy for
democracy for the country isn't it and
and
you know we went to too too much
opposition in 2017 to
19 and it brought everything to a
standstill but actually you know there
is definitely a place for uh for proper
scrutiny
right and and that's what as mps was
supposed to be about
and particularly opposition mps so it
does need to be more and
when you've got you know social media
companies making videos about what a
waste of space
kiss dharma is i saw a jungle book one
this morning that i particularly enjoyed
um you know it's it's not good and a lot
of people have been saying
as i said you know that there are
celebrities doing more to hold the
government to account
than than the labour party i think
captain hindsight's a
uh a good nickname because it's just a
case of going if i'd have been there at
the time i'd have done it differently
well wouldn't we all
um they've got a lot of their own
internal problems to deal with i think
before they can really get to
dealing with government but don't you
think that represents a fundamental
crisis in democracy ben like joking
aside because
if no one's going to hold you to account
then
what what state are we going to be in as
a democracy really
there's a big challenge at the minute
anyway through the covet stuff with all
the emergency powers and everything else
that
um you know the role of parliament is
diminished at the minute because we
we have given them those emergency
powers to um implement things
and come back and ask us afterwards in
hindsight and say you know would you
have done this and even if we say no
it's only a motion it's not a binding
vote anyway
um so that scrutiny is is very much
diminished and as a backbench mp
i wanna be able to go to parliament and
raise the things i wanna talk about as
well as just what government wants to
talk about
the westminster hall is gone you know
those opportunities have disappeared as
well so
it's not a healthy situation at the
minute if i'm being honest we need to
get back to a point
post all this health situation allows
where you know there is more opportunity
to raise
other things there is more opportunity
to to ask questions of government to
scrutinize you know
debates at the minute aren't debates
they're just a series of speeches where
you can't
um because it's all virtual so you can't
intervene on a minister you can't stick
around up and say
actually you said this and i'm not sure
about that um which is where most of
that work
kind of gets done in terms of scrutiny
so there is a void there
and it can't carry on that way and it
sounds like you're concerned
you know obviously i i take it that you
you support the measures
in the moment because of the extreme
circumstances but it sounds like you're
quite concerned about
some of the methods that are being used
uh
be becoming the norm let's say where the
government can just do stuff
without going to parliament yeah sure
you know
everybody including the government
accepts that it's not um in terms of
process down there it's far from ideal
at the minute
um they might you know be less worried
about that perhaps because it makes life
easier from from their point of view but
um
we certainly need to get back to a
position where we debate and decide
things before they happen
as opposed to afterwards uh the very
least you know and
and as i say as a venture it can be
difficult sometimes when you're
you've got certain things you want to
raise local priorities and normally
there are
a whole range of uh ways of doing that
at the minute a lot of those don't exist
because
we can't physically be there we can't
have meetings in the tea room with
ministers we can't have
um westminster hall debates we can't um
pop up in the chamber and ask questions
ad hoc it all has to be very planned and
rigid um
so it's not great but um you know it is
it's temporary
um and by the time we get to somewhere
i'd imagine it'd be back to normal
and you say back to normal i mean this
is a particularly nasty question but do
you think we're going to be faced with
another austerity program in order to
pay for all this
i hope not um rumors go around all over
the place donate the minute
i mean the irony is but um we're
probably gonna end up looking at
what i guess was the ed miliband
playbook um prior to 2015 in terms of
like spending your way out of crisis i
think um
i don't think that either the
conservative party or the country to be
honest would
um accept or would be happy with an
austerity round two
um but we're in a different position
right we're not in a position where
um the whole thing collapsed as it did
in 2008 and and we weren't in a position
to deal with it we spent all the money
and and we were kind of scrambling for
what to do it's much more methodical
we're in a better economic position
beforehand
a lot of the the impact as i say because
we've had
such a big range of business support and
whatever uh we'll be able to bounce back
a lot quicker i hope than we did after
2008
um but it will be you know be a
long-term challenge a difficult thing to
to do i guess hold on
you say we're in a better financial
position but we are in more debt than
we've ever been
oh right now yeah i mean mid covered and
all the rest of it sure um
you know we spend a lot of money and
we're going to have to to sort that out
but i think
you know the the investment in terms of
job creation in terms of
the infrastructure to support that job
creation and
you know improved skills and opportunity
is the way that we have to get out of it
and
rather than think of this as right we've
got five years or ten years to pay off
the debt which is what they kind of
thought in 2008
um didn't work did it so we're gonna
have to think about um
something different and it needs to be a
longer term plan which is gonna have to
be
you know yes we're gonna have to reduce
spending significantly from where we are
now let's
let's you know not be uh blase about
that we're spending hundreds of billions
of pounds on propping up things that
government should never be popping up
um you know so there is going to have to
be a lot of kind of rowing back on a lot
of the covid
uh things are back to the level of more
normal spending um
but we've got to invest whether it's
politically to to get those red wall
seats over the line next time or whether
it's for the economy and to create jobs
and to
shift people across sectors into new
industries um
is all going to take a bit of spending
too so no it's a short answer from that
big ramble
um no i don't see austerity mark two
because i mean you've got significant
challenges when we come out of this not
only do you have to grow the economy
once again
but you've also get got to go back
with the eu get everything running
smoothly again because obviously there's
been disruption because of brexit
there's stories coming out of the port
you know that people are waiting for
many many hours if not days to transport
goods etc etc
i mean these are significant challenges
that the conservative government
are going to face aren't they yeah i
mean we all knew post
um 31st of december that there would be
some disruption um
it's been much smaller than most in the
media would have had you believe it
would be
fortunately but there are some sectors
you know we've seen things that
particularly around northern ireland
particularly around fishing industry
where we need to find solutions and we
need to deal with
um some of the challenges and that'll
happen over the coming kind of months as
things come together and particularly
uh fortunately in some ways you know in
terms of that disruption that with
business being
much reduced at the minute you know
maybe there is that period
where clearly travel between the uk and
the eu is is nowhere near the
levels it would normally be which
perhaps gives us that window to to work
some of this stuff out
um over a bit of time we're going to
have to do that though and
you know rebuilding the economy relies
on us rebuilding
that trade relationship and getting all
of that working as well as the deals we
sign and everywhere else as well as
you know the opportunities as i said
like the the free ports and that
international trade and other places
and other things we want to do more
domestically now than we've done before
we're talking about you know more steel
production more energy production in the
uk
as opposed to elsewhere so there's loads
and loads of things to deal with
um i could find the capacity somewhere i
mean
and ben i wanted to ask you this because
i'm curious
you know viruses come along every now
and again this isn't the last one that
we
deal with what sort of assessment is the
government either doing already or
planning to do in terms of
of an inquiry afterwards where you
actually look at
whether the decisions that we've made
were the right ones
uh you know i'd like to see some
analysis
you know in the cold light of day not
now when it's all heated but in the cold
live day going
well actually we're locked down's the
right decision you know
how effective have they been what should
we do
if another virus comes five years down
the line because i think
we'd all accept that this has been less
than ideal to put it very mildly
yes and i'm not sure that the sort of
knee-jerk very very heavy reaction we've
had
is necessarily the one that you might
have had had you had some chance to
think about this in advance so
what are you guys looking at to
understand the best way to deal with
things like this in the future sure and
there needs to be that inquiry um
post all of this and and particularly
actually when we know
what the economic and social impact of
it is because part of the problem so far
that i've stood in the chamber and said
you know you're asking me to do this but
what is the impact of this you're asking
to lock things down but what does that
do in terms of the economy in terms of
mental health in terms of people's
education
um are particularly concerned about
schools and all of that ben there's also
simply the issue of health i mean this
is one of the things that really does my
head and about this
people don't seem to recognize that
lockdowns have a health impact as well
i want to know how many people die from
lockdown why are we never
never given that comparison because
surely if you're making a decision to do
a lockdown
you have to understand of course yes how
many lives you expected to save
but also how many people die and who are
those people are they young fathers of
three versus an 89 year old in a care
home
those are decisions that that you have
to look at yeah and we talked about you
know the things i
had international medicine about male
suicide and things like that we saw
after 2008 economic crash the amount of
young men out of work who
who committed suicide you know so there
are definitely those impacts
um i guess the challenge and what
government would say
is just that assessing those impacts in
the here and now you know trying to
predict what they will be is just
incredibly difficult
and it's such a complex picture isn't it
as to to what those impacts are even if
we know what they are because they'll be
hidden
uh challenges as well and there's things
like domestic violence things like child
abuse while people are locked up at home
and that we won't see the impacts of for
some time probably
so at least after all this we need to
sit down and say right you know what are
those figures
around all of those things around mental
health around domestic violence the
economic
challenges where does that lead us and
make that comparison if we can't do it
here and now at least need to do it
afterwards
and assess i think we figured some
things out already you know clearly
public health wasn't at all prepared um
for something on this scale
in the first instance spending too much
time telling people what to eat probably
as opposed to
um being prepared for for these kind of
things and they're going to have to be
so there's been a lot of investment and
um change there already and that will
change further so there's some things
we've picked up on
from the off but definitely you know
when sadly
you know the the social impact of all of
this won't be probably clear
um for a while and some of it will go on
for for
decades generations probably
particularly the schools and educational
side of things you know
and i think that i had a look at some
stats of the week there's a thousand
children in
in nottinghamshire uh excluding the city
so it's probably more like 2 000
children across the county and city of
nottingham and nottinghamshire
who are known to children's services so
vulnerable kids who need
you know intervention from local
government who are not at school
and we don't know what's happening to
those kids we're not normally teachers
would look out for them
um you know the impact of that on those
children is is going to be massive and
going to last for a long time
so there's going to be a lot of work to
do i mean
this is as a former teacher everyone can
drink now this is a thing that i'm
worried about and i think
and i'm in agreement with you i think
studies are going to be done
in the next few years to monitor what
has happened to this generation i think
you're going to see
increased levels of unemployment
addiction etc etc
as these poor kids have missed a whole
year of schooling
and it's not just the fact that when
they go back to school they're going to
be a year behind they're probably going
to be two years behind because not only
did they stop their education they
effectively regressed as well
yeah and you know whilst we already had
an inequality in terms of disadvantaged
kids and communities like like the one i
represent you know where the attainment
isn't as high
um more of those kids are not home
learning to
in the same way you know you've got um
kids from from
affluent families who or kids where
parents might be
furloughed at home or might be able to
do more work with those kids
in many ways if you're doing one-to-one
education at home you could be doing
more than you did at school if you get a
good quality
whereas other kids are getting nothing
or parents have to work full time from
home whilst they're looking after kids
and
you know you can imagine quite you 14 50
year old teenagers who normally would
have seven hours at school being looked
after by a teacher
just left for their own devices all day
every day scary and the internet in
their bedroom
they've got to be delighted mate well
yeah i mean it'd be a dream
for me as a 14 year old but would it um
be particularly beneficial for me in the
long term
probably not so that gap's only going to
widen and it's going to be a huge
challenge to pull it back because that
was one of the things we promised in
2019 that we would narrow that gap and
it's only going to have got wider over
the last year
it's fascinating having this
conversation with you because i almost
feel like
you're talking like a lefty from the
1980s talking about class inequality
poor working class boys etc but that
seems to have been the shift that has
happened uh
where you know when when people on the
left now
you know the left now talk about
inequality
they're talking at about it from a sort
of race sex
sexuality type of perspective um
instinctively you you strike me as
someone who who has a very strong
aversion to all of that
stuff am i right about that i'm glad you
noticed yeah there's
been some um some really interesting
studies into it all you know that the
the idea that um you know basically the
class war
failed and and now they've had to go and
find some other other groups
um on the left to choose as the next
people to rise up and overthrow
capitalism or whatever and we've gone
with with these identity groups it's
like a hierarchy of victimhood isn't it
where do we sit on the
on the list and how much grievance can
we find i think you know there are
are clearly you know racism sexism
uh homophobia very real very genuine
problems
um but to me just our problems of
individual attitudes they're not
systemic they're not
um you know our structures are not
designed to prevent
black people from from succeeding there
are other factors
um underneath that right and largely
it's social economic it's
yeah um it's about uh you know where you
grow up how much money you got how
connected you are to those networks that
can get you into
uh you know jobs and education and
opportunities and
that's the thing we've got to deal with
that geographical and economic
inequality
and and the rest kind of follows i also
kind of think that
you know attitudes have changed an awful
lot over the last 20 30 years
uh in terms of um you know the
the characteristics in terms of
homophobia racism
uh it's come on leaps and bounds it will
carry on uh personally i don't think my
generation
really sees those things as issues at
all um
or certainly the vast majority and that
will continue over time because that's
what we teach
our kids that's why i teach my kids that
those things don't really matter
um but the more we we kind of throw it
out in front of everybody the more we
make it front and center of the
conversation the more it does matter
because
that's all we talk about that's all we
focus on and i think it sets the whole
um the whole challenge back by decades
to be honest
i mean it does set the whole thing back
because it doesn't matter and this is
one of the things one of my bug bears
with the left it's
it doesn't matter what people on the
right do if you know you have a sadger
javid you know
everybody should be you know really
really impressed by what he's
accomplished regardless of his politics
you know son of a bus driver from
tooting
rose up to become a highly successful
banker then segued into politics we
that's a story that should be celebrated
surely but because he has the wrong
opinions
they use a whole raft of epithets
against him and in particular say he's
not an authentic asian person which to
me is baffling
that's how you know you're a progressive
mate yeah well
that's the been i think every um
you know every black or asian
conservative mp would probably tell you
the same i know
uh good friends with timmy bad knock for
example and she gets the same
we had it in the chamber labour mps
telling pretty patel that her
experience of racism wasn't genuine
enough um
you know it's it's mad and it is it does
become for them this hierarchy of
you know who is the most oppressed um
[Music]
my own experience is that the majority
of people who are supposedly
in that system of oppression don't
actually feel oppressed um
they would much rather get you know be
able to have opportunity and succeed on
their own merits than because of some
physical characteristic that gives them
extra
extra help and we find in the
conservative party all the time we talk
to conservative women about the idea of
all female shortlists and they're
they're horrified
largely because they don't feel like
they need that
actually to be able to get by they're
perfectly talented and capable in their
own right so
um it's a very divided conversation we
talked before about you know the
the division in these discussions and
it's another one that makes people very
angry on either end isn't it
um that's probably why some of the stuff
that i've said has had such a big
reaction but
i don't think it's healthy to just draw
everything back to those characteristics
um we had the international men's day
debate and i talked about
um i felt like everything always focused
around those things so i just want to
talk about blokes
actually you know not minority groups or
not whatever but just
kind of everyday blokes like me in
communities like mine
and i got slated for it and the labor
from bench beach brought it back to
men who were bme and men who were lgbt
and
like can we not just talk about men
full stock all men without right and
that will include those men
this is the thing exactly i just find it
it's so exclusionary
the way that these conversations are
being had i'm glad
glad you're speaking up about you
mentioned you're getting a lot of flank
and you certainly have got a lot of
flack
for for taking those views do you think
that
that is the understanding of these
issues that you've sort of described for
us is
is that something that people in your
party broadly understand or are you sort
of
the naughty boy with his hand up at the
back of the class at the moment
um i think i certainly probably used to
be but there is um
there's a lot of of understanding of it
a lot of people who
um agree very strongly but actually a
bit worried about
speaking out because they see the flag
that i get and they don't fancy it which
i understand
and a lot of those conversations have
gone behind the scenes and actually more
and more particularly from the 2019
intake because we've seen
that geographical shift right there
we've seen mps from
the midlands and the north from
different backgrounds representing
different areas who've kind of come in
and really shifted the nature of the
conservative party actually i think in a
really good way
um which means there are a lot more of
them who feel strongly about this stuff
and are willing to speak out about it
and there's there's different groups
that pop up i have a group called the
blue collar conservatives which is
more about those kind of values there's
one called the common sense group
and which is a lot of mps who look at
the kind of culture discussion
done a lot of stuff around the kind of
history and monuments and churchill and
whatever over the last year and
and just that patriotism element that is
is you know really valued i think by
communities like
mansfield and lots of others so there's
a lot of it going on
and some more more vocal than others uh
some of us perhaps draw a bit more flack
uh than others i've also felt like to be
honest because of of winning a seat like
mansfield and the nature of that history
and
labour still feel like it's theirs and
that makes me a bit of a target as well
to be honest since
since day one i mean one of the moving
on one of the challenges the
conservative government is going to face
it's it's almost going to be somewhat a
crisis for you which is a civil
liberties question
regarding vaccinations what legislation
is going to come in is
is it going to be no vaccination no job
uh like uh for instance
the the the chief at pimlico plumbers is
saying with new contracts you're not
going to get offered a contract
what is the government's position on
things like this and travel etc etc
yeah well i mean as far as i'm aware in
the conversations i've had there's no
no sense of that i certainly wouldn't
support a no vaccine no job policy
i think for you know we've got to win
the argument and we can't be a party
that says
um you know you can't shut down free
speech you can't shut down debate and
and accuse the left and then shut down
things that we don't agree with if we
want to convince antibacters to have a
vaccine we need to convince them
uh not well the thing is just sorry to
interrupt it's not only anti-vaxxers
that you need to convince that
actually as you were saying earlier
there's a lot of people who are not on
either extreme there's a lot of people
who are not
anti-vaxxers but they're not necessarily
convinced that a vaccine that's been
rapidly produced not had any long-term
testing we don't know necessarily what
the long-term impacts are
they're just sort of have a healthy
curiosity about that issue
it's not only the anti-vaxxers that you
need to convince i agree and you know i
talk to people particularly younger
people i think who are saying you know
what my chances of dying of this are
like
next to nothing so why why would i take
any kind of risk
on the vaccine you know a couple of my
um female friends in their late 20s
early 30s have said you know
what if it impacts my fertility in a
decade's time you know things like that
that we
maybe don't know um i can't pretend i
know enough about the science to say but
um we do have to win that argument right
if we want to have the vaccination
as widespread as it needs to be that is
something that the scientists and the
government need to explain and put
across and make sure that it happens
there's no sense to me of
um either by legal force or by coercion
being able to to say you must have it or
else i don't morally that that doesn't
sit well with me regardless of anything
else you know
i don't think the government should be
able to force people to inject a
chemical in their body if they don't
want to
um just not something i would ever ever
support but
i don't know um on the other end you
know you talk about pimlico public
plumbers i don't know what the stance is
in terms of if businesses want to do
that
um i don't know what the the position is
and we've seen we'll see all those
uh and areas that we can't control so
like if you want to fly to australia and
qantas want you to have had the vaccine
then there'll be nothing we can do about
that
um because it's not a uk company and
it's up to australia who they let him
um so i have no doubt there will be
examples of that
um around the world but it's not
something i fancy in the uk
no absolutely not i'm just moving on
just before we finish
the issue of big tech is rearing its
head we've seen
uh the polish government saying that
they're gonna find big tech
if they you know take down content which
doesn't contravene polish law
what is the government position on big
tech because it's going to become a
bigger and bigger issue
particularly as we go through you know
and as it becomes more prevalent in all
our lives
sure and it's another really contentious
one isn't it where almost the same
argument how
how much do you uh impinge on free
speech in order to keep people safe
um it's really difficult my own view is
that
um as you mentioned with poland you know
if it's not illegal
then it's not illegal i don't think and
we've seen in the last few weeks
uh peter patel talking about rowing back
on some of the kind of hate crime
legislation which i think would be a
really positive thing the idea that that
needs to happen
yeah that needs to happen it does you
know the idea that you can go to jail
from
being mean and saying some mean words to
somebody i think is is
absolute nonsense so we need to sort
that out and hopefully that helps to
deal with some of the online
conversation as well because in the same
way
you know at the minute um there are
people who have been
investigated by the police for saying
you know
women are women and men and men there's
absolute madness um
so we need to clear up what is legal and
illegal
offline so that we can clear out what's
legal and illegal online
i know there's a lot of concern um about
a kind of overreach on the online harm
stuff and
um and that limiting free speech but to
be honest i'd like to see it go the
other way i think the idea that
we should give all this power to mark
zuckerberg and
you know twitter and people to decide
what isn't isn't acceptable
uh in our online speech is just a bad
way to go
have you ever been abroad and felt out
of place because you didn't speak the
language
no because i voted brexit brexit means
brexit
i know that sometimes you're abroad you
don't speak the local language it's very
awkward like france is talking to a
woman
so you have to shout do you want to
learn another language
i don't for obvious reasons but if you
do
babel is quite simply one of the finest
language learning apps in the business
babel offers a clear and easy to use
interface they have
daily 10 to 15 minute lessons that have
been proven effective across
many studies showing that you can learn
up to 14 languages that they offer
so it doesn't matter if you struggle
with language maybe you find it
difficult to pick up or maybe you're
just
english right now babel is offering our
fans
six months free on a six-month
subscription with babel
using our special code which is of
course trigger that's
babble b a b b
e l dot co dot u k
slash play and use the promo code
trigger look at that spelling he learned
english on babel
i did but seriously go to babel dot co
dot uk forward slash play use our code
trigger
and enjoy babel and what would you say
to those people
go look ben these are lovely words that
you're saying and you know the
government try and do stuff but even the
uk government is powerless against the
might of big tech
we've got billions and billions of
dollars behind them
you know there is certainly um a lot of
power that's wielded there right and if
we're all on these platforms and if we
all
um you know give them all of our
information right the amount of people
who
um come to me and say i'm not going to
fill in this form i'm not going to give
you my email address because i don't
want
uh you to to have it and use it but i'm
quite happy to be on every social media
platform going with
um facebook knowing when they're going
to the shops and how long they they go
to the toilet each day
um you know we i think people don't
realize
how much data they they give away and
how much power that gives
to some of these companies maybe there's
more we need to do there to open that up
i certainly think one good thing we
could do um is make sure
and you know go work with these
companies to make sure that actually you
can't set up anonymous accounts without
any way of
of tracing people um i think that's
probably something that would be
good and healthy to have that
accountability um i know a lot of the
abuse and some of the threats that i get
come from from anonymous accounts where
nobody can really tell me or where i've
reported things to the police and
police can't trace people um so you know
maybe that's that's one step we could
take
yeah there's a few issues with that one
of them being like whistleblowers and
stuff you do want some
ability for people to remain anonymous
but i take your point
but it doesn't have to be publicly i
don't have to know
uh as a member of the public looking at
a twitter account who it is but twitter
should know
right and they should they should be
that ability for the government
or the police to then go right i'm
investigating this and you need to hand
over that information to me
um as opposed to you know it doesn't
have to be visible to everybody all the
time but
where things are illegal there should be
that scope
i see your point yeah there's some
issues with that that could be misused
there's certainly the idea of giving
twitter
more information about us is difficult
but you make the point
it's it's a difficult thing the one
thing i wish and
you know we've got you on the show so
when you when you cross
when you enter the door of number 10 as
prime minister one day
uh maybe keep this in mind mate uh one
thing i think politicians massively
underestimate is how much of your power
this is taken away
because these big tech companies get to
influence
you know elections at some point they
get to influence everything that happens
what people think what people get to say
who gets to be on it and i think that
will eventually come to
dilute a lot of the power that you have
from
the people and it messes with the whole
idea of democracy and i hope that
more people in in politics become aware
of that i think that's absolutely right
and
you know we've had the big discussion
about the state summary and that
election and the impact of media and big
tech on
on that you know i don't condone
anything donald trump's done i think
he's gone nuts to be honest but
the idea that twitter can silence the
president of the united states
is is not a healthy position regardless
of who that president
is um so there is a lot of work that
needs to be done
it's incredibly complex isn't it because
there is nothing that just is is the
right answer everything is a trade-off
um and it's a moral judgment there for
us to where you want to draw that line
but
you know there certainly needs to be a
real scrutiny and a real good look at
that and
it's probably top of the agenda from uh
uh
all sorts of points of view isn't it
whether it's free speech or or dealing
with crime or or
um just uh the online homes build that's
already being drafted as we speak so
it's gonna be a conversation we have
this year i have no doubt
fantastic well ben thank you so much for
coming on the show it's been an
absolute pleasure uh we the question
that we always ask at the end is always
the same which is what's the one thing
we're not talking about
as a society but we really should be
i think it's the thing that actually
we've been talking about but very few
others are and it is that
um that equality conversation you know i
think you do get
get shut down a lot when you raise this
and people are really uncomfortable
talking about um
different routes around that you know i
think that we need to do it very
differently and i think an awful lot of
people agree with me
um but it doesn't get discussed enough i
keep talking about you know
working class lads in communities like
mine who don't get the same opportunity
who are bottom of all the lists
and we have ignored that conversation
for a long time because it's not very
politically correct
and i don't think we can i think it's
it's increasingly important so
if there was one thing i would whack on
the top of the agenda it would be that
um
the one thing i would certainly hope and
i think i speak for everyone probably in
this conversation is
wrong piece of work nah now [ __ ] that um
no the one thing i would hope for is
that we stop having this conversation
in racial terms i just don't think
that's helpful
i don't think it's helpful to talk about
black kids and i don't think it's
helpful to talk about white
working-class boys
even in in the slight way that you've
done that i think we need to talk about
people who are genuinely disadvantaged
whatever their race whatever they're
saying
all of that i absolutely agree and i've
found it the most frustrating thing in
the world
that having got into parliament i'm
talking about disadvantaged kids i'm
talking about disadvantaged communities
working-class communities how do we
improve on this nobody paid the blindest
bit of attention
until i started saying white working
class boys and all of a sudden
it got loads of coverage we got debates
in the house and it got picked up
and that's the frustrating position we
find ourselves in right it's like i
mentioned with international men's day
unless you say um lgbt or bme or
whatever then then people aren't
bothered
and it feels like that a little bit and
that's a really unhealthy situation
because we do need to be
exactly what you said where actually
race sexuality gender is is not even
relevant to the conversation
it's just how do we help people who need
help and that's where we need to get to
so that's the where we need to start
with with what
things to raise and conversations have
well said
all the best of luck to you uh we will
be watching and as i say uh you know a
lot of our
a lot of our fans are like us sort of
floating voters and we will be looking
to see which way
uh the government takes these things
over the next couple of years
uh ben thanks for coming on the show
it's been a pleasure chatting with you
thank you good to see you
and thank you all for watching we will
see you very soon with another episode
like this one
or a live stream at 7 p.m uk time every
episode every
live stream take care and see you soon
guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button
so that you never miss another fantastic
episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below